I'm gonna do something
different,
which is I'd like to show you
a body of work that I've never
put together and shown
publicly like this.
It's a very short video.
It's on some big cats that we
photographed a while back.
(music begins)
(music continues)
(music ends)
(applause)
Musi: If you have a question,
I'd be glad to try and take
a whack at it.
Right, there's one
right here in the front.
This...right next to you.
There were all those
really intense pictures.
Musi: Mm hm.
How did... did you establish
some kind of relationship
with them?
How did you get them
to look at you so intensely?
You know we built...
We did those pictures
in thirteen days.
So we did uh, eight big cats,
and we built a studio
for each one of them
in the enclosure
that they spend time in.
So, sometimes it was
literally black paper,
we put a cheetah on.
Otherwise, sometimes it was like
huge sheets of plywood
that we made black.
And then, we would
light it in a way.
So, these were spaces
the animal was comfortable in,
and then, uh, it was just
really a matter of time.
Sometimes it was a
very brief thing,
'cause we never
stress out an animal, you know.
They, they say what I do
is enrichment.
Musi: And I'm like,
"Well they're screaming at me,
- and they want to kill me.
- (audience laughs)
And they're like, "No, no,
that's enrichment.
It's good for them."
They always say,
you only get to, like,
put your hand in the
cage but five times.
Each finger... Right?
(audience laughs)
So, you know, we built
a studio for each one of them,
and tried to kind of psyche
out each one as a really
distinct personality.
You know?
The, the lion was hard.
You know, the lion
was in my face.
We did him twice.
We had to build a
thing that pushed him
back a little bit,
'cause he got right in my face.
And he was so big,
I couldn't photograph him.
He was huge.
And the cheetah,
you know, cheetahs
are kinda chill.
So, it wasn't
a big deal to work with him.
And then we had
a snow leopard,
and man, she was torturing
me for a couple of days.
And, and I sang to her.
I started singing...
So... and that broke
out into tongues.
And I started doing
all this like...
(babbling)
...and everybody was
just staring at me.
And I, like, collapsed on
the ground, 'cause she
just stopped...
(audience laughs lightly)
and, like, hold... and she
never went to being mad
at me after that.
It was like I hit some note,
and it happens...
I go and I, like,
collapse on the ground,
I'm laying, in cat urine...
And I say, you know,
uh, "What just happened?"
And they're like,
"We're as surprised as you.
We have no idea."
'Cause it just happened
like that.
So each one is
a little bit different.
It's just patience, honestly.
Woman: The tiger there?
Oh, that tiger.
There, was a big tiger in there.
And, you know, I'm always
sort of relying on the expert.
"Tell me if I'm stressing
him out. Tell me..."
And the tiger, you know,
I thought he was
getting a little...
His ears were coming out.
I said "Are you sure
he's not getting mad at me?"
"No." And I said,
"Well how will I know?"
He said, "You'll know."
(audience laughter)
No, I said,
"Really, how am I gonna know?"
He said, "You'll know.
And, and this went on for
a while, and you know,
we photographed him
for quite a while, and then
at some point, he put out
this roar
that, I mean, shook my core.
(imitating roar)
It was like, it was
different than anything else.
And, he said,
"That's what I was
talking about."
(laughs with audience)